if I told you that in Another Universe
Earth could be shaped like a donut well
you'd probably think I'm crazy but
theoretically it could happen this
alternate Earth might also be squeezed
into the shape of a dumbbell or it could
even be
flat okay maybe that one's a bit harder
to pull off but Earth could be many
strange and different shapes today I'll
take you through seven of the weirdest
possibilities some shapes can be
incredibly
dangerous While others might be better
in some ways than what we have
now number seven dut
Earth on a donut Earth or a Taurus
shaped Earth as the science Community
likes to call it gravity would be very
different depending on where you're
standing you could weigh up to three
times less than what you weigh right now
our current round earth has a surface
gravity of 1G but things would be a bit
different on a donut Earth at the poles
the surface gravity would be 65 G's
while near the equator it would only be
03 GS you'd feel like you're bouncing
around on
Mars also the moon would act strange it
could behave in two different ways it
might be pulled toward the hole and bob
up and down in the middle like this or
it might be affected by the gravity of
the Donut's outer edges and create this
figure8
movement this would affect the ocean
tides and cause unstable water levels
destroying cities that sit on the coast
the weather in certain parts of the
planet would also be extreme massive
hurricanes and storms would be wreaking
havoc now despite these problems it
would still be possible for humans to
survive on this planet sure some places
would be inhospitable and it might be
hard to travel due to the low gravity
but we could live
here number six dumbbell
Earth okay this next planet Falls a
little further into the realm of Science
Fiction but let's go check it out anyway
this is dumbbell Earth it's two separate
planets connected by a narrow middle
section the gravity in this part would
be significantly weaker the middle
section would essentially being pulled
in two directions by the outer planets
this would create some extreme volcanic
activity which might cause the planets
to break apart Crossing between the
planets would be incredibly dangerous
and in some cases impossible due to the
gravity now living on either of the
outer earths would feel pretty close to
what we have now they'd have similar
gravity weather and atmosphere the main
difference would be that each Earth
would have different cultures and
Technology they might evolve differently
and contain completely different
species number five ellipsoid
Earth okay this kind of Earth would be
egg-shaped not the sphere that we're
used to it would still be habitable but
there'd be some major differences from
how we live now gravity would be
stronger or weaker depending on where
you stood on the planet the more narrow
parts of the planet would have the
strongest gravity and The Wider sides
would have weaker gravity you'd also
notice some differences in the weather
places along the Equator would have a
broad range of tropical milder
temperatures and places near the polar
regions would be much colder and have
more extreme temperatures than what
we're used to but overall apart from a
few differences a planet like this would
be very livable for us
humans number four flat
Earth
okay before we have some fun talking
about a flat Earth let's make something
crystal clear a flat planet is
impossible and we definitely don't live
on one gravity naturally shapes massive
celestial bodies into spheres so a flat
Earth would completely alter our
understanding of
gravity and it's just
impossible but living on a flat Earth
the air pressure would be a major
concern
gravity would draw too much air toward
the Earth's center leaving the areas
around the edge with no air pressure at
all if you lived in Australia you
wouldn't have enough oxygen to breathe
and if you lived closer to the Arctic
you'd be crushed by the weight of the
air You' also have to consider that a
flat Earth wouldn't have a core and
therefore no geomagnetic field to
protect us from solar
winds everyone would get a serious case
of radiation poison in from the
Sun number three Cube
Earth Earth now has six sides
unfortunately none of them are any fun
that's because walking on them would
feel like you're constantly climbing up
a super Steep Hill on this cubed Earth
gravity is strongest at the center of
each of its faces so the further you are
away from the center the more you'll
feel its pull but maybe you won't notice
it after all you'd only be able to live
near the center of each of its sides
that's because due to this Earth's
gravity all the water would be pulled
into the planet's multiple centers the
edges would be Rocky and Barren unable
to support any kind of life it would
also make traveling to the other sides
of the planet incredibly difficult or
impossible people on different sides
would likely evolve in different ways
and each side would have a different
climate and weather
a side that doesn't get much sun might
be incredibly frigid whereas a side that
gets lots of sun would look a lot
different number two Hollow
Earth now some of the planet shapes
we've seen on this list are
theoretically possible but a hollow
Earth is anything but that gravity would
force the hollow Earth to collapse on
itself essentially creating a smaller
sphere but let's assume that didn't
happen
well there still wouldn't be any life
because there'd be no atmosphere yeah
there would be no magnetic field because
our core would be Hollow no magnetic
field equals no atmosphere and not
having an atmosphere would mean a
ridiculous amount of solar radiation
from the Sun would be frying us plus if
you somehow managed to land on this
planet well you'd instantly fly off a
hollow Earth's gravity would be so weak
that nothing could stick to it this
planet's shape kind of sucks
next okay for this last one we're going
to cheat a little bit what you're
looking at Here is known as an Alderson
disc it's like a DVD version of Earth
and it's less of a theoretical Planet
shape and more of a mega structure that
could possibly be
created but we'd need a ridiculous
amount of
materials you'd likely need to mine the
entire wealth of minerals from planets
like Earth
Mars and a few others making them
completely
uninhabitable and this disc would be
massive able to house billions and
billions of people it would be
241 million km wide for reference the
circumference of Earth is just 40,000
km but the people living on this
Alderson disc would only be able to live
in the middle of the band closer to the
hole near the Sun would be extremely hot
and the edges of the disc would be
incredibly
cold yeah there's also another major
issue with this Mega structure since
it's so big there's the chance that the
disc could collapse in on itself and
create a black
hole yeah I don't think I like this one
now maybe instead of contemplating these
crazy shapes of alternative Earths we
should appreciate what we have right now
maybe in the future it'll progress in
all sorts of interesting ways like maybe
becoming a type seven
civilization but that sounds like a
story for
another what
if